- Я давно вже не вивчав англійську.
Я її практикував, але
можливості перевірити свої знання,
в принципі, не було.
- Не знаю, як у вас, у мене
така, більш-менш yes-no.
I want to swim by two hands but not now.
Thank you so much. Two tea tea
tea. Ok, it isn’t for me. Це про мене.
- Hello guys! How are you
today? My name is Nataliia Liashko,
let’s start the English lesson!
Hello guys! How are you today?
- I'm fine, thanks.
- What about you, Svitlana?
- I'm fine too, me too. And you?
- Oh yes, thank you very much
for the question. I'm feeling super.
Yes. So, today we are going
to have a lesson on the internet.
And I have a question to you
– do you like using internet?
- Yes, of course, of course…
- Yes, I use internet like… every day.
- Internet it’s our life.
- Our life is the
internet. Yes, of course.
So, let’s have a look.
What can we do with the
internet, on the internet?
So, what can we do on the internet?
- We can search something.
- Search the information, okay.
- Speaking with someone.
- Okay, so, chat with friends probably.
- Watch films, listen to music.
- Listen music, watch video clips.
- Fantastic! That’s nice!
- «Світла сторона музики».
- Okay, what else?
- Study.
- Probably for us, Svitlana, we
are girls, we love doing what?
- Makeup tutorials?
- …Look – oh, shoes!
- Ah, online shopping!
- Online shopping, yes, of course!
- Okay, so, let’s look at some
activities that we can do on the internet.
So: watch films, listen
to music, do shopping,
chat with friends and
check the news. Agree?
What's your favorite among these five?
- Watch? Oh, let’s, like in school, yes.
- Okay, Svitlana was
first, let’s go with Svitlana.
- I… In the internet…
- On the internet.
- On the internet I…
Best of all for me it’s:
watch films, listen to music, do
shopping and check the news.
- Check the news. So, you don’t
like chatting with your friends?
- Little bit… No.
- Okay, this is your priority, okay.
- Fima, what about you?
What's your favorite?
- I will choose only one.
- Okay, which is?
- I like watching films. I don’t
like listening to music usually.
Watch films and that’s all.
- That’s all, okay. Let’s stick
to watching films, that’s nice.
And can you, please, listen to me?
We are doing or watch
the films on the internet,
we do shopping online on
the internet. So, on the internet.
Repeat after me – on the internet.
- On the internet.
- Bravo, okay. The last point on
the board was checking the news.
Okay? It is important to check
the news and to stay informed.
Right? This is important for people.
So, I'm going to show you some
headlines, some news from the internet
Okay? Let’s have a look at the
picture. But, as you see, there is a gap.
One word is missing. So, I give you
5 words. Delivers – what is delivers?
-Deliver is when you should
get somebody to somewhere.
- Take something and
give it to somebody else.
- Somebody, somewhere, yeah.
- Okay, good. What is bends?
- I don’t know.
- Bends – this is
something that for example,
my watch can bend around my wrist, bend.
- Ah, like belt?
- Similar. So, I can translate
– гнутися. Okay? Гнутися.
So, my watch goes around my
hand – гнеться навколо моєї руки.
Okay? Like this – bends. Interacts?
We are actually interacting now.
- Chatting?
- Yes, so interacts means –
exchange words. Okay?
So, transports.
- Okay, we understand.
- So, this is like moving. And welcomes?
- Welcomes it’s like arrived?
- Invite?
- Welcome – when I welcome you,
I say: “Hello” to you, I smile to you.
So, I welcome you. Привітати, запросити.
- Щиро.
- Yeah. So, let’s look at this
particular news.
No one at the wheel!
Driverless bus, blah-blah-blah,
passengers around the city. No driver.
- No driver? I think that this is bends.
- Bends? So, the bus bends?
- No.
- Okay.
- Delivers!
- Delivers.
- Or welcomes…
- Transports!
- Okay, yes!
So, this is the driverless bus that
transports passengers around the city.
TranspOrts, repeat.
- TransOorts.
- Yes, we say trAnsport but transpOrts
- TranspOrts.
- Okay, let’s continue.
So, we have new one. The same
words but a new piece of information.
So, the mail’s landed! Drone…
- Delivers?
- Aha, okay. So, Svitlana,
you had a question.
- What does it mean – parcels?
- Parcel. Have a look at
the picture – this is the parcel.
Посилки, пакунок. Okay, what
about this one? Robot receptionist.
- Robot receptionist… Welcomes!
- Yes! So, welcomes guests
to the department store, right?
So, she says: “Hello!” and invites
people to the shop. This one?
- Athlete… With virtual world using
virtual reality gym equipment. Wow.
- Bends?
- Are you sure?
- No! I think interacts!
- Yes, because we have with.
- Ah, interact with…
- Yes, so, interacts with.
I'm interacting with you and
athlete interacts with virtual world.
- Too quick for me…
- We have with, which
helps us. What about his one?
- Flexible smartphone, yes, we are sure…
- Bends!
- Yes, exactly, bends!
This is actually a very nice smartphone,
looks nice, you know. Very stylish.
- It’s a real smartphone?
- I don’t know… We can google.
- Yes! I saw, yeah-yeah there are
such smartphones. Around the hand.
- So, remember these
5 pieces of information.
So, these are five news
on the internet, okay?
I'm going to read the message for you
So, this is a real information
from the internet, okay.
Try to think – which one
I am discussing? Okay?
What I'm talking about.
You need to guess.
Number 1, 2, 3, 4 or 5. Ready?
- Yes.
- So, you listen and tell me which
information belongs to which news.
So. “Yesterday afternoon,
a minor crash brought traffic
to a standstill in Hereford city center
The incident involved a public
bus colliding into a parked taxi
on the corner of Khem
street and Oak road.” Fima?
- I think that this information
is about first news.
- Yes, okay, let’s check…
- I was first!
- You were the first, okay.
So, this is easy because
we hear the word…
Which word helped you, Fima?
- Transport, traffic, crash.
- Yeah. So, actually it could
be a bit confusing with number 2
because there is drone
who delivers parcels, right?
But when you hear the word “bus”, “taxi”.
- City center…
- Yes, immediately –
this is the bus. Good.
Thank you very much!
Now, a task for you and
the task for our children
who are watching the lesson. Okay?
- Okay.
- So, what can we do
on the internet? Hold on.
- Fima, hush…
- I'm giving you 5 seconds
to remember the words.
To remember those words.
Okay? Ready, steady!
So, what were the words?
- Together – watch films.
- Bravo!
- Together – listen to music.
- Amazing.
- Shopping online.
- Bravo.
- And… I don’t remember.
- …Chat with friends…
- Yes - Chat with friends!
- Amazing!
- And… 1, 2, 3 – check the news.
- Wonderful, students! I'm amazed.
Okay, let’s check the
information. Was it correct?
- Ah, do shopping!
- Bravo! Do shopping its okay.
You do shopping and you shop online
– this is also possible, no problem.
Do shopping, go shopping online.
It’s okay. All of them are possible.
Now it’s grammar time.
Ready for some grammar?
- Yeees! Yes, captain!
- So, I have a question
– do you like grammar?
- Yes, very!
- Okay guys, hush.
- Yeah, sorry.
- So, today we are talking about
Present Simple versus Present Continuous.
What’s the difference
between these two things, okay?
And we’ll study with a little situation.
We’ll study with the
conversation between two girls
So, let’s have a look:
- We’re going to the mall this weekend.
And we always go there
on Saturday mornings.
Do you want to come with us, Jane?
- I’d love to, Mona but this Saturday
I'm going on a day trip to Bath.
-And this is actually a joke. Because,
can you have a look at this word? Bath.
- It’s like a… “ванна”?
- Yes, this is like bathroom.
But this is actually not true and
Bath is the name of the city in England.
That’s why it is kind of a joke.
Because Mona, she wants to go with Jane
but she's got a trip to “Bath”.
So, let’s have a look at these
examples that I highlighted.
We have 4 sentences.
We are going to the mall.
This is Present Continuous.
Okay? Why it’s Present Continuous?
We are going to the mall
thing weekend. So, it’s not now.
We are going to the mall this weekend -
this is actually like future but
we are talking about it now.
- You have to use Present Continuous
when you are…
Збираєтесь щось зробити.
- Okay. We call – fixed arrangements.
- Yeah, going to.
- Bravo! Going to is a bit
different but this is the same.
Do you want to go with us?
Do you want to come with us?
This is Present Simple.
Why it’s not Continuous?
- Because it’s now…
- It’s like proposition in real-time.
- This is like an
offer in real-time, yes.
- There is no time. “Do
you want?” – and that’s all.
But we are talking about
now… Actually, can you imagine…
Можете собі уявити процес хотіння
саме зараз? Як це так – процес хотіння?
Я почала хотіти, зараз
хочу і продовжую хотіти?
- Ну, це звичайна жіноча, така, тема.
- Це дівчата, так? Можливо
тут Present Continuous.
- Okay. So, we call it state verbs.
So, this means that this verb –
want – we can’t use it in Continuous.
Yes, like love. Can you imagine:
“Are you loving me now?”.
But in a second “you don’t love me”.
So, this is happening now, so we
can’t use this verb in Continuous.
Let’s have a look at this one: “I
am going on a day-trip to Bath”.
- I'm going – it’s like in first…
- Yes, like in the first example. The
same – fixed arrangement in the future.
Okay, so let’s summarize.
So, Present Simple tense.
We use the Present Simple,
we’ll start with Present Simple,
with habits or routines.
So: “I leave my house
early every morning.”
Habits – that’s something
that I do regularly.
“I do yoga in the morning”,
for example. Let’s move on.
So - permanent state or situations.
“Does he work in the bank? Yes, he does.”
So, permanent – стабільне. Okay?
“Does he work as a teacher? Yes,
she is a teacher”, for example. Okay.
Let’s move on.
So - programmes and timetables.
“The gym doesn’t open on Saturdays.”
Or, for example, “My
flight departs at 5 o'clock –
this is scheduled”.
Okay. And – general
truth or laws of nature.
“In winter it snows in
the mountains”. Okay?
Okay? Or, for example: “It’s
really hot in summer”. Right?
Or: “The water boils at 100 degrees”.
- General truth.
- General truth. Good? Let’s
have a look at the trigger words.
Trigger words – these are the words
that we see the word and we understand –
this is Present Simple.
- Like usual.
- Okay.
- Every day.
- Yes.
- That’s all.
- Sometimes. Have a look: every
hour, every day,
every Monday.
- Every something.
- Yes, every Sunday, every summer. Okay?
In the morning, in the
afternoon, in the evening.
What else? At night, at the
weekend, at 5 o'clock. Good.
On Monday on Friday, on
Saturday and so on and so forth.
We see these words –
we immediately understand
that this is Present Simple tense. Okay.
Now, let’s revise the formation.
How do we make positive,
negative and questions?
Positive sentence, negative sentence.
- З якого слова ми
починаємо будувати, так?
- Yeah, how we make up
sentences? Do you remember?
- If you will show
example for us, we’ll see.
- Yes, I’ll help you.
- Ah, these ones, yes.
Yes. So, these are positive sentences.
With I and we, we just take the subject
– підмет – and then the verb. Right?
I play football. I cook breakfast,
we play football, we cook breakfast.
But the difference with
he, she, it. So, we add…
- Закінчення -s.
- Yes. Negative – you
see, the verb is the same.
But we have don’t or doesn’t.
This is the auxiliary verb
– допоміжне дієслово.
And questions. So, we
put the auxiliary verb first.
Do I play? Does he play?
Or - do we play? Okay?
So, let’s summarize.
Positive – no auxiliary.
Negative and question – we
have auxiliary – do or does. Okay?
Let’s move on. Present Continuous.
This is a boring part but let’s make it.
So, we use Present Continuous
with actions happening now.
We are talking now. Yes?
“We are making
video-lesson for the students”.
This is happening now. “We
are exercising a lot these days”.
Why these days? Because
this is not only happening now
but around now – те, що
відбувається не тільки зараз,
в момент мовлення, а й ще час
трохи більший, ніж момент мовлення.
- So, it will start and will finish.
- It is still in process. These days.
So, we are staying home these days.
Correct? We started and
we are still staying homes.
We are staying homes these days. Good.
Fixed future arrangements.
Do you remember
“I'm going to Bath”. So, “I'm
not visiting gym tomorrow”…
- … because I'm going to Bath.
- Yes, “because I'm going to Bath” or “I'm
not going to the mall”.
Correct as well.
Good. Currently changing
and developing situations
That is something that keeps on changing.
“My English is improving”.
“My yoga is improving”. Or: “My
bank account is getting down”.
- Become better, yeah?
- Become better, yes, changing situation.
Okay, we use Continuous as well.
And the last thing – with always or
constantly to express annoyance.
So, we are annoyed. “Why
are you doing this all the time”?
So, have a look at this example.
The person is listening to music
very loud and it drives me crazy.
So, I want to express my annoyance. “You
are always playing your music too loud”.
In order to express this annoyance – “you
are always playing your music too loud” –
you can say this, Continuous. Okay?
- It’s like only rule
you have to remember.
- Yes, these are the rules
that you need to remember.
Trigger words?
Not always or every day.
- Now?
- Now, good. What else?
Tomorrow? No?
- No, these days, at the
moment and nowadays.
Nowadays is similar to these days
and at the moment is similar to now.
Okay? So, simply, this is happening now
and we are talking about this. Formation.
Let’s have a look. Positive
sentences, we have:
I – am; he, she, it – is; you,
we, they – are. Fantastic.
And we have -ing ending all the time.
So, the thing that is changing is actually
to be verb. Am, is, are. Am, is, are.
Am, is, are. Only this
thing changes. Okay?
- Yes.
- Good. So, now it’s quiz-time.
- Yay! Game! I like games.
- This is not a game. A game is
going to be a bit later. Quiz-time!
So, I'm going to check you. Have a look
at this sentence. Is this correct or not?
He plays tennis every day.
- Yes, it’s correct.
- Correct, let’s check.
Bravo! It is correct. Number 2.
He driving home now.
- He is driving home now.
- Let’s check. So, it’s not correct. He
is driving home now. And one more.
- They are…
- They don’t drive.
- Okay, they don’t drive to work on
Fridays. Yes, amazing! Fantastic students.
Okay, let’s have some practice.
So, we have two people talking.
- Yes, okay.
- Jane and Mona, for
example. Or Svitlana and Fima.
And we have to open the
brackets. Simply to ask the question.
Have a look. La-la-la… to
work every day. Not always.
This week, he… the train into the
city because the traffic is so bad.
Let’s start with number 1.
- Does your dad drive to work every day?
- Yes. We have every day.
So, this is Present Simple.
Does your dad drive home
every day? Not always.
This week – Svitlana, maybe you try?
- This week he is take the
train… Takes? He takes! No?
- Are you sure?
- He is…
- So, have a look. This is not always.
This is this week. So,
this is a changing situation.
- He is taking.
- Bravo.
- Oh, -ing, закінчення.
- Okay, so, can you read
the whole sentence, please?
- Not always. This week.
He is taking the train into the
city because the traffic is so bad.
- She is amazing, isn’t she?
Okay, let’s move on.
One more phrase for you.
…Mia/usually study in the evening?
Oh yes. Actually, she…
her homework right now.
- Does Mia usually study in the evening?
- Because we have in the
evening, right. That’s why
“Does Mia usually study in the
evening?”. Okay, and the second one?
- Oh yes. Actually, she is studies…
Ah, she’s doing.
- We have right now.
- She is doing her homework right now.
- Let’s check. Yes, she is
doing her homework right now.
- Все, я зрозуміла. В першому ти вставляєш
does, а потім я -ing закінчую. І все!
- It doesn’t work like this!
Always watch for trigger words.
In yellow – in the evening.
What's this – in the evening?
Try to remember – in the evening,
trigger words, we had every hour,
every week, in the morning. Ah, in
the evening – so this is Present Simple.
Right now?
- Present Continuous.
- Bravo! Okay. So, you
always watch for trigger words.
This will help you.
Now, let’s play a game!
- Let’s play a game!
- Let’s play a game?
- So, do you like knots and
crosses game? You don’t like it?
- No, we like it.
- Excuse me, one more
time, how it… what's the name?
- Knots and crosses. Knots. And crosses.
This is a knot. And this is a cross.
Knots and crosses. There is one more
name for it. It’s called “tic-tac-toe”.
“Tic-tac-toe” – the name of the game.
But we got to the name “knots
and crosses”, this is easier.
So, have a look. Nine spaces
Here we have positive sentence.
Negative sentence. Question.
- Yes.
- And here we have she,
I and we.
So, if I want to put my
cross or a knot here,
I need to say a sentence.
Negative sentence with she.
And we’ll use Present Simple. So,
the Present Simple with she will be like:
“She doesn’t like milk” or
“She doesn’t go to the gym”.
-Yes.
- Okay. If I want to put it here,
Fima, positive sentence with we,
give me an example, please.
The present Simple with we.
- We like play football…
- Yes, we like playing football.
- Every day, every night.
- Yes. Svitlana, if I want
to ask a question with she?
- Does she… Fima!
- We have only one, does she
like play football every night?
- Does she like playing
football every night!
Okay, so, ladies go
first, don’t you mind?
- Oh my god!
- So, Svitlana, you choose. What
do you want? A knot or a cross?
- I always win with a cross.
- A cross, because cross is always
start. So, you will have a cross.
Fima, you’ve got a knot. Cross is start.
Svitlana, where would
you like to put you cross?
Okay, give me a sentence.
- I always try to be beautiful?
- This is nice, okay. So, your
cross is here. Fima, your turn.
- I don’t like listening to music.
- Fantastic.
- You have a big problem. You
have a big problem in your life.
- You have a big problem
because I have no in the sentence.
- I guess you're banned. Okay, so,
Svitlana, continue. Your second sentence.
- She… She always takes the breakfast on…
- As.
- As a takeaway.
- Bravo!
- Fima?
- I think there was some
help from you, okay, okay.
We like when
boys are champions.
- Wow, this is a really nice
sentence. Boys are the champions.
We are the champions! Svitlana?
- Does she play football in the evening?
- Good. Fima?
- I think that she doesn’t like
playing football in the evening.
- Good, okay. That’s serious.
- We… We don’t like fake news.
- We don’t like fake news! No,
we don’t like fake news, I agree.
- It doesn’t matter but…
- We need to finish, okay.
- Does we like friendship between girls?
- Ooh, again, please?
- Do we like friendship
between girls and boys?
- Okay, so, it’s like this. And for
you, Svitlana, just finish the sentence.
- For fun.
Do I take fitness in the morning?
- Do I have a fitness class in
the morning? Yeah, like this.
So, there is no winner.
There is a tie. We call it a tie.
- Oh.
- Yes, нічия.
- Or a draw – нічия – yes. We don’t say
friendship, we call it a tie or a draw.
So, your homework guys. Write 5
sentences using the Present Simple
and 5 sentences using the
Present Continuous. Okay?
And there is a bell. Unfortunately,
we have to finish the lesson.
- Unfortunately.
- Thank you very much.
- It was cool.
- Thank you so much it was
very fun and very… Пізнавально?…
- Useful.
- Useful!
- Useful! Thank you very
much, see you next time!
- Боже, це так хвилююче, я так не
нервувала навіть перед концертами своїми.
- Сьогодні був простий
урок, але я помилився,
мабуть, один-два рази я помилився.
Тому що – це іноді занадто
просто і мозок виключається.
Ну, ти думаєш: «А, я це зроблю
на 100%», а потім помиляєшся.
- Цей урок надихнув мене під час, можливо,
карантину зайнятися англійською мовою.
В Present Continuous
будується запитання так…
Фіма!?
Спочатку дієслово, тобто does
she play football in the evening?
Playing!
Is she? А is she? Як правильно, Фіма?
Is she, okay. Is she playing
football in the evening?
Every day? Right now. Cut!
Залиште ще Фімі, будь ласка!
Now, at the moment and that’s all.
I don’t remember all but
all these words mean “now”.